sorry this is all the women in white
that I think it is evidence of the many
places where for thinking about data
it's really respected so okay well thank
you very much it's a being a delight to
be here over the past few days and and
listen to people Helen you're not meant
to eat in here and so yeah it's really
been fascinating listening to the
conversations and getting many of the
ideas that you have put forward I'm very
I'm delighted I've actually helped to
partially fund that Berta Noura
conference back in the day adam
remembers and and was there and to watch
a field flower the way this is flowered
it has been terrific it's it's really
interesting and useful so what i hope
that you take away from the the
discussion that i'm going to have today
is what i'd like to do is to have the
considerable brainpower in this room
think about how to address may be
questions that I think are more
important
okay privacy however to find information
whatever is incredibly valuable
and what I'd like to kind of get you to
think about is the kinds of questions
that I'd been facing and I think the
country is facing not just this country
but other countries up close and
personal okay so this is going to be I
should have been titled this a view from
the trenches not from Valhalla not that
you're dead yet but you will be soon
hello
but women can't go to Valhalla so as I
was going through this and as I was
thinking about this and I'm gonna
apologize to Adam for as my discussant
because of course I did change things
and if you haven't seen the changes but
that's okay
so it occurred to me that really the
title is wrong it's not making data
great again it's making measurement
great again so I want to talk through
why measurement is so important so
clearly we're I'm gonna head is a
discussion of risk and utility
associated with that measurement and and
why the why the particular use cases
that I'm going to be talking about I
hope you hold dear to your heart when
you're writing down the abstract
descriptions that you have done so
beautifully over the past few days so
I'm academic so I'm gonna tell you what
I'm gonna tell you then I'm gonna tell
you and then I'm gonna tell you what I
told you right so obviously we got
massive types of new data that I have
completely fundamentally changed way
which we can do research for the public
good and also as you guys pointed out
there's a downside risk associated so
but I'm gonna focus on the good side
because that's what I care about so what
that means is because you guys have to
focus in on the bad side
I think there are three issues that I'd
like this community to be thinking about
the critical role of access for
measurement I'm going to spell out what
that means more something that Freya has
highlighted and Helen and others the
link between utility risk and the
trade-off between the two and
understanding what that trade-off is and
Coby gave me a fisheye earlier this week
when I said think about protecting
output more than inputs so I'm going to
tell you what I'm thinking of and then
you can tell me how stupid I am but
that's okay my husband does that all the
time and we're still married and I think
it's what I'm going to pose to you is I
hope I'll convince you since you're all
high-functioning academics that this is
an important but very difficult research
agenda so what I'm hoping to hear from
you at the end is you know when you talk
to some people you'll they'll say ah but
that's really hard and what I'm hoping
that you'll say is oh that's really hard
right so so so here's where we're going
to go so here's the new types of data so
I think that the type of data that
you've been largely thinking about is
data generated by surveys which are
nicely curated documented collected rows
and columns where the measures have been
thought about for a long time and
someone in a Federal Statistical agency
has said this is how we're going to
measure it and here it comes you may
also have been thinking about
administrative data but typically just
one offs like tax records or
unemployment insurance wage records
where social scientists like me and life
scientists lots of other areas in which
we think about confidential data data
that are also collected in a variety of
different ways that may not be rows and
columns so this is Charlie Catlett's
work at the University
Chicago where he has that you know
senses that are capturing information
every ten seconds about particular
quality lots of other things you said
colleagues at NYU for those of you who
have been in New York the number one
complaint is noise right which is a
ephemeral hard to measure and they've
been using sensors to to capture the
information on noise which of course
includes conversations hello darling my
husband's off tonight come on over right
oh so that's capture not those words
would ever come out of my butt you know
capturing that information it's got a
very different structure retail scammers
DNA information all of those don't come
in nice tidy rows and columns and so and
a lot of the administrative data about
which I'm going to talk a lot now don't
come in a pre packaged nicely documented
pre-measured format so I'm originally
from New Zealand this was not a New York
accent and and so I'm going to give you
some kind of foreshadow some of the work
that was done in New Zealand and give
you some sense of the value of having
and combining data from multiple sources
and give you a sense of the challenges
that are associated so New Zealand like
any other government you know kind of
has the major buckets of spending or
education health pension and you know
what we did in the late sorry 2000 2001
was start to build an integrated data
infrastructure so what that means is
when you're looking at spending people
touch programs government programs in
many different ways and if you're trying
to allocate resources in a government
program what you are interested in doing
is capturing all the different ways in
which they might be
so that you can figure out get a better
handle on how to best deliver services
both to the benefit of the individual
remember I'm told about the public good
here
and for the benefit of the public purse
so here's an example so this kid is born
and you can look at data from
administrative records from Children
Youth Family Services and you'll see
around age two and a half the kid starts
touching so children need family
services and there's findings of abuse
at age five they start into the
education system by age nine or ten the
attendance and the education system
spotty and you can see the cumulative
amount of costs that's coming up across
these different agencies by age twelve
or thirteen showing up with abuse taken
into foster care here gaps in education
they're not showing up at the school and
then in and out of care then come about
17 they're showing up in Youth Justice
about 18 they're showing up an income
support and there's the cumulative costs
that's coming up so you can put those
pieces together and you know look at the
likelihood of the kid achieving school
certificate the equivalent of a high
school certificate by age 18 and if you
you know obviously your risk of don't
spiraling down is very much increased if
you don't get that school certificate
and if you take a look at risk factors
now with all the decisions and issues
associated with those risk factors
you've got the clearly low risk kids
most of those are going to get the
school certificate and a bunch of high
risk kids
and really when you think about
allocating resources well you really
want to do is is provide one-on-one
interventions with those kids to to help
help them get the education
qualifications so they're figured out
from the school systems you've got
you've linked all the data from the
integrated data infrastructure you
figure out whether or not a kid is going
to get the education certificate and
then you model so the one of the things
with the IDI is that we started it I was
on we were building the le HD in the
United States and so I spent a couple of
weeks three times a year for two years
in New Zealand and we started to build
basis for an integrated data
infrastructure and then we got lots of
agencies to share their data and now
within government agencies any policy
that is developed they look at the IDI
to model the the risks and the benefits
associated with any type of intervention
now the models may or may not be good
those risks may or not be correct but
that's the kind of analysis that's able
to be done and it's even and you're
going to hear about why I care about
doing those links correctly and doing
those models correctly and getting lots
of eyes on those data right so you're
actually setting it I think you're
setting me up perfectly so why is it so
why is that happening
well obviously part of the reason is to
make increase the chances of the
children getting education keeping them
out of abuse also it substantially
reduces the cost to the taxpayer and of
course the the costs are attributable to
kid to clients who enter the benefit
system under age 20
and the data on these requires linking
data across agency lines and it requires
measurement it requires people within
the agencies and the research community
so this is in partnership with social
science researchers making some
decisions about how to measure things
okay could be wrong right so there's a
new opportunity in the United States and
this is the Commission on evidence-based
policy and the reason I put that in
there is they talk about data in the
center they also talk about privacy
rigor capacity humility and transparency
and so this is how I got kind of pulled
into the into a lot of the discussion at
the federal level was that when the
Commission was established by Paul Ryan
and patty Murray Owen B gave the funds
to census to inform the decision-making
of the of the Commission and one of
those things was we have to be able to
put those administrative records
together so just like the IDI which
started in New Zealand 2000 2001 now
they're really thinking about building
an integrated data infrastructure in the
United States they call it
administrative data carry on so census
asked me and my colleagues at University
of Maryland and University of Chicago to
think through what might that very house
look like well I don't like the term
Clearing House so we changed it to a
facility and they were thinking about a
technical environment whereby data could
be put together and I served as the
chair of the IT committee for when they
set up the administrative data research
network in the United Kingdom and one of
the things that was very in
about that is in the UK they'd recognize
the same thing a few years earlier ESRC
had spent 38 million pounds about fifty
million dollars to build an
administrative data research network and
so that agencies would put their data in
what a shock agencies didn't write so
why didn't they lots of different
reasons one is bad data bad analysis bad
documentation no upside risks just
downside risk and so what we what we
decided to do is it was critical to
build the capacity in the government
agencies to work with their data list
you know data get integrated in a bad
way or bad decisions get made or
measurement errors creep in and so on so
that's what we did we jointly built this
administrative data research facility
and combined it with a set of applied
data analytics training programs to
train the government agency staff how to
work with the data okay is there a legal
framework is there a legal framework so
that's a great question of course the
any data that are to be combined have to
essentially there's five different
buckets and that every agency has to
think about they have different
legislation and that needs to be
reconciled but it's essentially safe
people it has to be approved people it
has to be safe projects approved project
it has to be a safe setting it wants
really safe setting safe data so ideally
de-identified not clearly anonymize data
and safe outputs okay so with every
agreement
that was put together that was the core
focus of the agreements between the
legal entities of the government
agencies so absolutely there have you
can't that's why the notion of a
clearinghouse is a non-starter it's got
to be for a purpose of food people and
so on notion that you're just going to
shove data in and you're gonna play it
it's just not going to happen and and
I'm gonna argue that this we people
worry obviously about privacy but I'm
gonna argue that it's absolutely
critical to do something like this so
there's a great quote from Liana when
Baltimore's a very violent City as
you're probably aware and as she says
every time a kid dies in Baltimore the
commissioners of all the agencies that
they touch so in the example in New
Zealand children new family services
education a foster care criminal justice
income support they'd all get together
and figure out what did they do wrong
and how could they improve for the
future but the only time they get
together is when the kids dead right so
the heavens in the United States as well
so many of you will be familiar with the
kid five year old kid who died a couple
of weeks ago and what kind of happened
was the the kid the police went saw the
kid had a brew bruise on the right hip
Family Services had been involved since
he was born
so the welfare system had been in
there'd been 40 different contacts from
different agencies on the kid he told
the doctor doctor wasn't allowed to
share the information for privacy
reasons and that's a kid who died so you
know
the challenges of course that when we're
trying to put data together so this is
an abstract little X's and Y's these are
kids right so the problem is that when
you're putting the data together the
data are messy and dirty as you just
pointed out they're not nicely curated
so here's an example when we were
running the class so we brought together
data from different agencies so the
question going back to the authorized
purpose the authorized question was what
is the impact of access to jobs and
neighborhood characteristics on the
earnings and employment outcomes of
ex-offenders and welfare recipients and
their subsequent recidivism and
retention on welfare so we had people in
the classes from city county state
federal governments and they're working
with micro data on corrections
ex-offenders on welfare recipients on
labor markets on housing and they're
trying to answer that question in teams
because no one knows the people in
Corrections don't know the data on labor
the people in labor don't know the data
on TANF they don't know the housing some
people know how to code others know them
their data some people know how to
structure a question and produce results
that make sense because they're at the
coalface they understand what measures
are going to have value to answer the
questions that are going to inform
policy so here's an example here they
are working with it and these are data
that have actually been curated they've
got a data dictionary and here is
Eleanor she's working on it hi do see
Department of Corrections data geek
gurus why am I getting junk here this is
on track and the CIO says adds bad data
ignore it now without having people
working together looking at that
measurement you could have had bad
analysis or you could have spent 20
days or months trying to call the person
to figure out what's going on and they
wouldn't have returned your calls right
and then here's someone else in the
class saying okay gee this is Clayton
who's saying here's some code that could
be useful so we're gonna share code and
then someone else from Connecticut who's
saying oh here's some here's a sample
that's going to help you do your job
and there's someone else Rick Kendra
from MDRC
who's saying here's an article that's
going to help you understand the context
so the point here is is that back when
we were dealing with survey data of rows
and columns which were nicely the
questions and measurements had been
predetermined and discussed we got the
data set handed to us on a silver
platter by trained statisticians and
survey scientists so we had a data set
the point here is the data come at the
end of the process not at the beginning
okay so and there's lots of things that
get found out so for example you think
about one of the outcomes that they were
interested in is did an ex-offender get
a job
what's a job is that many jobs are
fleeting lasts less than a quarter about
twenty five percent of all jobs worth
less than a quarter so one of the teams
started to put together a picture of the
ex-offenders because they were able to
link the ex-offender data with the
employment records and they were able to
see that only 3% of the extenders had
jobs at last that lasted eight quarters
or had employment in each of a quarter
so it couldn't may not have been the
same employer and the rest is spotty and
then a bunch here is missing then of
course you start saying well why is it
missing well I could be missing for many
reasons it could be that they are not
employed or it could be there working in
Indiana or it could be they've gone back
into Corrections or it could be they're
on welfare they could have gone into
education I need to match that data to
understand what missingness is
and I can't ask them because it's
administrative records and so you need
to be able to look at the actual data
and codify the decisions that are being
made in order to be able to share the
information there are thousands of
decisions that get made in that
measurement process and and people need
to see what you've done so why do I have
linnaeus up here other than that I'm a
proud half Swede well because if you
think about measurement obviously that's
what he did he started to do measurement
and Buckett things and what you want to
do is you want to go and look what did
he actually look at when he was creating
his buckets when he was doing his
measurement I want to look at the source
and what I'm trying to argue here is
that that's what we need to be thinking
about and there's lots of privacy issues
associated you know obviously he's
looking in a plant I want to look at the
individual people level records so that
when I'm thinking about measurement I
can see how other people bucket it does
that make sense and how other people
were thinking about it so and data sets
are not well defined entities in this
world this is relatively simple because
it's administrative data it's not sensor
updater or or retail scanner data or so
on so this is this has kind of units it
has this as Human Services data but it's
still as my Uncle John would say a right
mess right and people are going to pull
from it in different ways construct
measures in different ways and so on
linkages can be wrong how many of you in
this room get mail to only one name how
many of you get mail to 20 different
mates I have a pretty easy name
you wouldn't believe how many different
versions and butchering was they can do
about it and of course you want to have
people looking at those linkages and
thinking about you know are those
algorithms wrong I don't want to have a
corporate entity coming in and making
those linkages and saying oh it's
alright I made those linkages without
think about you know what precision
recall trade-off was being made and just
say oh here's your links because you can
have different loss functions associated
with that and the cleaning of the data
prior to doing the linkages is a hell of
a lot of work because you have to
standardize and and I don't need to
spell that out for you and measures need
to be generated to some extent through
trial and error you know seamless have
github and so on share information
here's an example that Bob Gege and
Emily Wiggum did with the corrections
data so let me give you another
real-world example so in Corrections one
of the things the director of the
corrections was interested in is the
impact of technical violations on
recidivism so technical violations are
something that or you didn't report to
parole every week and if you have a
technical violation you're back in jail
so that creates lots of costs to the
individual because then of course they
can't work it shows up on their record
they could lose their job because they
can't show up to work and it costs the
state and so what he wanted to do was to
see what is the effect of technical
violations or what's a relationship not
a causal what's the relationship between
technical violations and recidivism and
so what Bob and Emily did with working
with people and in the in the classes
was they started to try and bucket them
so they took this individual level data
and they started to describe and
created categories and then looked at
the different categories and then looked
at their earnings and then said you know
if you take a look at this the technical
violations the the people who had very
low technical violations were able to
find employment it's not causal but it's
a it's an initial set of thing so the
point is is they spend a lot of time
working with a micro data to generate
measures they weren't generated by a
survey statistician and handed to him so
the issue is is to work with that I
don't need to tell you this almost all
social and economic activity is highly
skewed so you know most health care
costs are from a small proportion of the
population most businesses don't do a
hot-dog grow very fast there are a few
businesses that I have grow quickly and
so on most there's a few people who
commit most of the crimes so looking at
the outliers is actually where most of
the policy issues are so you know our
challenge here is the core thing is that
the more I work with the data the
greater the utility of the analysis but
obviously and mrs. George Duncan and
Steve Weinberg's picture after culture
the source the greater the risk of the
disclosure and part of the challenge
that we're facing is that trade-off is
getting worse and worse so one of the
things that would be very helpful for
you guys to be thinking about as you
think about privacy is it's not a
one-dimensional thing and we should also
be thinking about what is the utility
trade-off that's associated with that so
how do we think about utility timeliness
is super important if you're trying to
implement policy I don't want that kid
to be dead right accuracy is obviously
one measure coverage
geographic detail consistency and then
the number of ways in which it could be
used so I might go to that in too much
detail because I I'm gonna run out of
time and then what are the risks
so obviously re identification is going
to be related to how noisy the linkages
might be whether you've got a sample
versus a census there are very different
reagent ocation probabilities if I've
got a small sample versus all the people
in the population are we thinking about
individual harm and you've been talking
a little bit about that here and then
not all items are the same like do I
care if they find out that I'm a female
do I care if they find out that I'm an
ex murderer probably and they might care
about finding out if I'm a female if I'm
actually transgender and I'm living in a
neighborhood in which I might be a
problem at though there's because
they're contextual stuff right so and
here's my concern is that while you have
a very useful and important research
agenda it is having an impact on the the
quality of data that is being produced
and consequently potentially the impact
on the value of that date of the
decision-making and in fact you had
Steve Ruggles here I know that that
Census Bureau people have been here and
and Steve has probably put it more
forcefully than most but a very large
portion of the policy community is
deeply concerned about the way in which
a research agenda is being
operationalized without thinking about
the impact on policy and utility
so I understand that the census I am far
from an expert in the census but I do
know that it's used to apportion
representation and at that scale I'm
curious whether it's whether how much
how much noise we need to add and how
problematic that is I understand that
like lots of things one does with the
census is like such but get a much more
refined scale the like knowing how many
people live in 100 square mile radius we
should probably have that conversation
offline because that might take a very
long time to discuss there's a
constitutional thing that has to do with
specifically apportioning maybe one
three point is family in here is that
the there's the decennial census which
is you know where people live and some
yeah and and then there are the much
more detail and their survey is like and
sort of the complexity of the issues are
sort of very different than they did yet
in many ways the decennial census is
sort of easy yes that's exactly yes
yeah and and that's exactly right out of
it there are many problems but the
challenge that I think is being
transmitted is that differential privacy
is going to be a silver bullet that
solves all problems for all agencies and
all and that is certainly the message
that is being heard in the policy
community and so I think better
communication and better understanding
of for what purposes the types of
approaches that are currently being used
versus you know the potential is is is
is an important one and kind of getting
you to think about other use cases is
this is a little bit just to put this
question out there without necessarily
addressing it but it the two cases that
you that really struck me felt very
different in relation to this part of
your discussion the one about child
welfare this should be no confiscation
we need to know you which child it is so
that you can but then the one about
literacy you know it may be that in that
case we want some policy to come out of
statistical knowledge and so it's like
how much money should be spent to
retrain or you know that kind of issue
which doesn't require going back to the
individuals no they're not and I'll talk
about i I'm glad that you brought that
up because I think the next couple of
slides will make that clear but yeah
there's a difference between policy
analysis and case management so the case
management I need to know who the kid is
and and get some information out but
I'll give you an example of kind of a
hybrid approach in just a second which
actually comes out of the Allegheny
County example with which I'm reasonably
familiar and then the that the my point
on the stood on the development of
statistics to inform policy is that
there's a lot of eyes that need to be on
the development of those statistics
prior to them being generated
one is I think normally assumption is
that if we do research and we get some
interesting findings that they are there
will be action that happens and you know
that many of the issues that plague
whether it's people who've had
interactions with the justice system or
kids in foster care or who are having
interactions we have all the research we
need at this point to address like
eighty five percent of the problem we
just have no political will right and
that would be this is this is a position
I'm putting out there yeah I like the
second is that you know this in the u.s.
in particular you know there's a
specific reason that like Paul Ryan was
advancing evidence-based policy and it's
partly minded the data quality act and a
full postive things because we lack a
precautionary principle right and so
there's a very conservative agenda
around driving and I'm obviously not at
all opposed to evidence-based
policymaking it's just in the u.s. it's
part of a gnarly set of things that are
designed to make it actually more
difficult for Oregon for administering
agencies in particular to do things that
protect the public when we're not clear
about the risk right and so I was not
pushing the federal agenda I was pushing
the state and local who are at the
coalface who are trying actually to
develop measures and
me as you know like the SS state local
level which is what you're talking about
there's actually been kind of I think a
real and part of it is about Code for
America and part of it it's about a lot
of things that happened during the Obama
administration that really helped
develop a more robust understanding of
what data can do for good but when we
saw Trump come in and a different
immigration policy
you saw all of those same agencies going
holy crap we have to get rid of all this
data and it was speed of the sanctuary
City policies most of those are about we
need to be able to allow people to say
that they are part of our community but
not actually retain earnings data about
them we need to allow people to present
themselves for services without
collecting any data about them and so
like the politics of this is so
important from my perspective and I
totally agree that we need data to make
their choices but I think that the
assumption that privacy is like anti
utility which is often how its presented
in differential privacy generally but
also in conversations about research
ease and an action is just it's it kind
of attorney always misses the nuance of
the conversation because data and
evidence are just like it's a political
act the whole thing and so I just and I
know and this isn't to take away from
the importance of all of this work at
all it's just like I want to remind
everybody that there's this broad
political apparatus in which these
conversations are carved correct no no
question yeah as usual you've put it
perfectly um so yeah I'm not gonna
expend all that you've made the point
good no no no and and and so taken so I
want to commend
on this and things that you said that no
decisions of privacy are taken without
taking policy issues I think that was a
bit too harsh I think all of this
community and we worked with the sensors
we know that a lot of issues are taking
together into account in the decisions
that they are making it's not that they
are ignoring Steve Ruggles or I wasn't
I'm just saying that there were two
sides and I was putting both of them up
now I'm not I think our role as
technologists as the pivotal study
privacy from my point of view is to
understand the the real trade-off
between what between the utility and
then five surgically and this is what we
can supply policymakers with now you
would make a decision it seems that to a
large extent what Raghu is asking for is
contradictory to account card
understanding of privacy and one cannot
have both in a sense and you will have
to make a decision on this balance and a
third comment is a premises an
overloaded term and does not apply
necessarily all it does not apply in all
places where we use the word privacy and
one one thing I would ask from you is to
look at these cases and ask exactly what
is the privacy desiderata that you
believe is relevant for that story for
that use case and we'll take that try to
formalize it mathematically and tell you
to what extent it is a
ringing or disagreeing with the utility
that you're trying to get I've got a
deserter otter at the end and that's
exactly what I'm I'm hoping why I was so
delighted and honored to be able to come
and talk to you guys because I think the
conversation has been muddled and I'd
really I think clarifying the enormous
contribution that can be made would be
extremely helpful and become many of the
concerns that are being raised there I
think it's fair to say that the label of
alarm is very high because of the well
I'm not going to I'm not going to assign
reasons but I it is very high so let me
just talk through what in some of the
issues that are being raised and then at
the end I'll talk through the desiderata
one of the issues is of course how do
you measure privacy neutrality that was
kind of the discussion that prokhor many
of you were at that workshop and very
grateful for your figure and put on that
so going back to the Allegheny County
case so the reason I know about this is
it was Kiwis
we've got who are involved in in the
example I forget who talked about it the
other day it was you wasn't it wasn't
you didn't okay so going back to the
family the child abuse thing so you're
gonna think my entire family is
economists but my brother-in-law was
involved in this but but here was
basically the idea so you know you asked
about the predictions so essentially
what they do is they they look at the
kids and they put them in buckets so
they say here's your risk
you know people call up and they say
because next door's getting hit and you
know you want to know about the other
ways but you know what they'll do is
they put these into a into bucket so and
this would be a very high brisket so the
kid who they've integrated the data
across Allegheny sounded so the kids
whose picture I showed earlier that
would have shown off as a high-risk
individual so when the caseworker they
use their own judgment but then they
also get an indicator of the risk that
that kid is in using using data to
figure out what's going on and when you
think about the so there was an impact
evaluation of this approaches done at
Stanford the results came out May 1st
and the so it was an impartial
evaluation and it actually reduced
racial disparities improve the accuracy
of maltreatment screening and that was
so so going back to there are many areas
your point is well-taken on immigration
but there are many areas in which this
information can really help so you know
trying to think about how you could
build a data infrastructure that
incorporates privacy and confidentiality
into the core of the decision-making is
kind of part of the desiderata here we
this is not being able to pull people
like you into a major research
infrastructure effort you know we see it
in many other areas
Alex LA you know you know the sky server
an astrophysics the spun off massive
research interest and going in my
daughter was also an economist my cousin
is the finance editor for the London
economists we breed you see the sheer
opposed to going to the BA as a dungeon
and she sits there she does the work or
by
self no one to talk to no one to compare
I'm very confident of course her work is
high quality of course but it does worry
me that most of the people who are doing
the work on confidential Micro data an
RDC is a graduate students and so part
of what we built was a virtual RDC in
which the data user is collaborating
working with brain granger and jupiter
notebook and and Fernando Perez who you
all know here at Berkeley to to build
that collaboration but access it's at
the core so kind of as part of this data
infrastructure and again stealing from
Charley Catlett building not standalone
hidden data but an infrastructure where
you can search and discover and find out
what other work people have done what
measures have been used
what linkage decisions have been made
because we don't have the Federal
Statistical system doing it
you've got people working in teams with
different understandings who need to
collaborate and that's kind of the
genius of Amazon which has done it in
the private sector I'd like to see that
in the public sector so that data
discovery and I'm conscious of the time
we want when people are looking at
publications to know what data sets are
available so that's part of futures
funding what data sets were used in this
paper what who are the experts what code
books what annotations have been used to
build a coral reef of knowledge and
that's not a set of one-offs
that is repeated building of an
infrastructure so what I'd really like
to see in a infrastructure is an
integration of these approaches that's
my that's my my call to some extent in a
pathetic attempt to increase the
readership of our book we actually did
to work on this but this is the I'd like
inference and privacy and
confidentiality
as part of every policy class that uses
data and every data science class that
uses real data because people need to be
working so I'd like you to be and your
point is well-taken but at least think
about that in in concrete terms as your
think about how the data are being used
so here it is so here are the kinds of
things and this is a first set of
requests and there would be many more
I'm sure if we get these conversations
going so maybe think about use cases
more general than the Census Bureau
state and local you know we talk about
what is reasonable means what does it
mean to say what's reasonable means
different measures of risks based on
access description so Cobie asked you
know what are the restrictions well in
some sense it's not 0 1 if you only
allow access to approved trusted
researchers in a safe setting where
they've signed an NDA not to re-identify
and so on you might have a different set
of criteria than if it's out in the wild
versus never released and think about
you know let's think about approaches
that we can generate summary information
that like that bucket score the twenty
to one that doesn't that provides
information that that has value to
decision-maker so so you're not in I did
find me I did find the individual kid
but you're saying you know we got
worried about this one you know don't
think about all observations equally we
can be looking at subsets of data think
about the measures of utility and I know
you're thinking about this but I think
this is a very hard problem
there are complicated variable
structures that might need to be
addressed
don't treat all fields equally and and
think about access and measurement and
more people we have think about
measurements better of you am I on time
[Music]
thank you very much
and my apologies I have a plane to catch
because I have to teach tomorrow morning
so I'll be leaving at around 11:00 10:45
to catch my flight that leaves at 10:30
at Rockford so the time zone differences
kill you yes but I've got you on video
oh yeah you keep your I will keep it I
just need to turn it off
so thank you Julia for that the talk and
and for raising a bunch a bunch of
really crucial crucial issues so I just
wants to know no I mean only the title
changed okay anyway so you know just to
reinforce some points that came up you
know utility has many facets of course
and something that you know we see
community tend to think a lot about sort
of numerical measures of utility or like
various kind of quantitative measures of
utility but we don't necessarily think
about things like well you know what's
the cost in terms of you know timeliness
what's the cost in terms of ease of use
I mean we think about these things in at
some level we understand that they're
there but you know making them more
salient is never a bad thing yeah at
least at some point in the spectrum
between kind of pure research end of
things and actually getting things that
change the world in real life you know
Julia made an excellent case that you
know thinking of the census or you know
the other big use cases we we tend to
play with like Apple and Google you know
that's great but there's all this other
all they're all these other places where
data and measurement matter and people
make decisions and you know thinking
about these sort of broader applications
again brings up things that we that are
maybe not a salient when you're looking
at super well curated data in a point
that came up over and over was sort of
the question of access and and there
were just many aspects of it and I
wanted to end unpack a few quickly so
one is that yeah you know one of the
things that came up a lot in the talk is
that you know you need ways to actually
see the data that matter at the time
they matter and that broadly is what
computer scientists would call access
control and and that is an I mean it's
that's not an easy problem but
conceptually it's a very different
problem from the kinds of dis
closure control problems that you know
have been some of the topics for this
workshop in this semester and and it's
an interesting question to think about
you know whether or not that took that
conceptual division is perhaps
oversimplifying the relationships
between these issues so just you know
case in point when I if I think about
linked data that are linked across
agencies when we merge and link data you
know what what rules should be applying
to the to the these sort of linked data
sets and also what problems and new
pathologies arise because we've
concentrated data in these you know and
it concentrated access today right so on
one hand this is important you know the
the child abuse case is a fantastic
example of how you need information to
get to where it needs to go but but of
course you know concentration of data is
in some sense concentration of power you
know what what comes with that and like
I yet another kind of access you know
aspect of this which Julie was sort of
talking about at the end with our DC's
is that we need sort of better
approaches to letting people work
directly with data and yet having
rigorous ways to talk about what they to
release the results of those analyses
and and this is sort of I'm not going to
dwell on it just because Cynthia and
John wrote a paper about this recently
in a chemo race talks so far this
semester but that you know they dubbed
this the Feinberg problem because Steve
would do Feinberg would often you know
hammer this point home in his own very
forceful way and but it's an improv you
know absent Steve to do it it's a good
thing too just a quick point Steve was
one of the original organizers of this
program and so being
and and what come one of the things that
you know computer scientists struggle
with is that you know the the things we
do with data and this came up again in
Julia's talk aren't well-defined
processes you know they're it's not a
because it's not a well-defined
algorithmic pipeline it's very hard to
reason about rigor so it's finding
better ways to do that is important just
so quickly some related research
problems dealing with small samples you
know that that matters that came up I
came you know Julia was talking about
outliers and how much they matter and
the the problems of doing things with
outliers and and disclosure control are
technically involves a lot of the same
problems as dealing with small samples
so outliers are sort of troublesome
statistically it's hard to understand
how much statistical power you're really
getting because on the other hand
they're sort of crucial for our
understanding but of them like we we get
a lot like just as humans we get in a
data analysis task we get a lot bite out
of looking at the things that don't fit
our current model we need refined
notions of statistical utility I kind of
talked about that earlier so I was
typing these notes as we're going so
they're a little disorganized and then
you know better tools to incorporate
data uncertainty in our reasoning about
confidentiality and disclosure control
data are messy they're noisy they're
sampled we have some tools for thinking
about this for like when we really
understand sampling distributions well
for example and there are a number of
papers that are sort of trying to
incorporate various measures of data
uncertainty but they're they're hard to
apply for reasons that
and then one another research sort of
area that I think is he's interesting is
you know how and I mentioned this in my
unbaked ideas talked earlier on Monday
was like you know how do we collectively
decide how to use the data we have okay
so one thing that I think has not been
well digested by you know communities a
lot of communities is that you you can't
release if you can't do everything you
would ever you can't release everything
you'd ever want to know about it dataset
without basically release so there are
trade-offs that come right now we don't
understand we don't even understand what
trade-offs the census has been
implementing because we don't understand
how much noise there is in the things
they release but how do we kind of
collectively as research communities
make these decisions
can you just I can give you citations I
can give you pointers offline I'll just
go through quickly so let just some last
points that I wanted to bring up access
control versus disclosure control we
need better language for that and in the
outside of computer science that
language has to be understood more more
carefully because I think these problems
are often confused
another point to remember is that
traditional even traditional disclosure
control is like by no means necessarily
operating at a very good point on the
trade-off between utility and error and
you know one speaking of the kind of
current controversy over the censuses
decisions there's sort of this under
assumption that when the Census
publishes things that look like micro
data those those can be taken as real
data but they're not and they shouldn't
and and of course you know just again
something to remember is that when we
you know all this is huge these huge
amounts of data we have they they bring
with them new pathologies and so you
know I liked the word humility on that
evidence-based book policy me for you
know computer scientists may need a dose
of humility but I prefer it when it's
other people I mean all right anyway and
maybe one last last point is that you
know underlying a lot of what's going on
is that we we want processes that
automate all these decisions about
getting information one one place or
another making it easy to release
information all that thing all all those
types of decisions anything you automate
you are mathematize a meth you are form
formalizing the problem whether you
think of your task that way or not right
because once you build a system that
that does something automatically you
have built a mathematical model for your
problem so if you think about it that
way you'll probably make better systems
than if you just then you know if you
kind of somehow think that like you can
you don't really need to formalize it
took reason formally so then I'll stop
with
[Applause]